she was one of my favorite people in the
world
and i will miss her so
we will receive the news of her passing
with both emotions of deep sadness but
also gratitude for a life that was
utterly and completely devoted to the
service of others
i had the opportunity to meet her before
she passed and she was an incredibly
gracious and decent woman
the thoughts and prayers of the american
people
are with the people of the united
kingdom and the commonwealth and their
grief
i feel like she's my mother or my
grandmother you know that's how i felt
[Applause]
[Music]
i was deeply sad to find out about the
death of her majesty queen elizabeth ii
said ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski is a heavy loss for all of
europe for the world
[Music]
i've grown up knowing the queen all my
life and then her passing away it means
so much for me to come here and lay my
own flowers she's always been here she's
been a constant my whole life you know
she's just been
leading us you know the right way i
think
[Music]